نعود الى الدوحه عربيه نايف اهلا بك هذه
المره نتحدث عن مباراه المغرب كرواتيا كيف
كانت الاجواء
لله امانه كانت يعني لو نتكلم عن الاجواء
ما بعد المباراه يعني
بالامس كلهم متواجدين في الفندق المنتخب
بعد وصوله من الملعب كان هناك يعني
احتفالات
اهازيج من جمال الجماهير المغربيه ايضا
كان هناك يعني تصوير مع اللاعبين كانوا
الجميع سعيد للانجاز الذي حققه المال
المنتخب المغربي بالتاكيد انه كان الطموح
ان يصل الى نهائي كاس العالم ولكن حتى هذا
او حتى الثالث ولكن المركز الرابع انتصار
كان هناك يعني اجواء جميله في همم محيط
همم الفندق وايضا يعني همم حسب همم
البعثه المغربيه انه همم سيكون هناك حفل
واستقبال جماهير شعبي وعصمي للمنتخب
المغربي استقبال همم الابطال النظيف
الانجاز الذي حققوه عنده وصوله الى المغرب
ان شاء الله
نعود الى اجواء اليوم
منذ ان بدا المونديال والارقام
والاحصائيات وحتى تعليقات المتواجدين في
قطر تشير الى ان مشجعين منتخب الارجنتين
هم الاكثر والاكثر عددا هل مازال هذا هو
الجو الطاغي هل من تفسير حتى اليوم لقلت
وجود ربما الفرنسيين ومشجعيهم
يعني
تقريبا 45 دقيقه في الموقع هذا اغلب
الجماهير اللي موجوده كلها من الارجنتين
يعني نادره تشوفين جماهير ال- ال- المنتخب
الفرنسي في منطقه تبعد تقريبا يعني 35
دقيقه وهي منطقه مخصصه للجماهير هناك يعني
مستوطن عدد كبير جدا من الجماهير الى
الارجنتينيه همم في هذه المنطقه وهي
المنطقه مخصصه لهم ايضا زادت الاعداد
عندما تاهل المنتخب الى همم المنتخب
الارجنتيني الى النهائي هم اكبر عدد
جماهيري منذ بدايه المونديال يعني كانت
الاحصائيات الرسميه في دور المجموعات
50,000 جنيه كانوا يعني يتنافسون مع
الجمهور السعودي والجمهور البرازيلي هم
كانوا اكثر ثلاث همم جماهير تشاهدين في
المناطق همم العامه همم نادين همم يعني
همم انا ممكن يعني همم صار لي فرصه ان
يدخل معهم همم
الجمهور يعشق كره القدم بشكل همم جنوني
محب للكره محب لميسي محب ل همم بلده همم
يعني لا استغرب يعني الحماس وكما ذكرت قبل
يعني اغلبهم حظر بقروض بنكيه او همم قدم
يعني حضور المونديال على اشياء مهمه جدا
هذا العشق موجود يعني لدى البرازيلي الذي
الارجنتينيين يعني جنون حتى داخل المدرج
متعه لا يضاه هي متعه عندما تكون حاضرا
لمباراه طوافها المنتخب الارجنتيني انا
يعني اتكلم عن نفسي انا انهم يشدون نظري
احيانا عن المباراه بسبب مشاهده همم